- My husband's still
looking forward to it.
We have a three year old,
and he's still looking forward to it.
- Oh.
- Like he's like
"It's gonna be so exciting."
- Three is a wonderful age.
- They are, it is a threenager though,
but yeah, he's our boy.
- He's a threenager?
- Twos were fine, threes are
the devil has actually
come inside their body,
(audience laughing)
- And I need an exorcist.
- So you're drinking communion
every night?
- I drink a lot of communion.
(laughing)
I just, it wasn't my fault.
Jesus changed that water into wine.
He taught us correctly.
- That's right.
- Yes, I don't need water.
Are you bothering them to
have grandkids yet though,
because now they're out of the house?
- Oh yes, in fact I do it nationally.
Like every talk show I go on.
Okay, what camera should I look in?
This one right here, okay.
Boys, just letting you know.
The first one that gives me
a grandchild gets the house.
(audience yelling)
- Oh my gosh!
(audience applause)